[Applause]
you got the tiny west definite crawlin
I'm liking it a lot of a lot of show
tonight I got to address something no
cuz it's not everybody's minds lately
I'm talking about the economy our
economy is in some trouble at the at the
moment some people doom and gloom sayers
are comparing this crisis to the Great
Depression and I'm just not so sure that
we can draw that in where's that singing
coming from it's coming from me bah bah
bah boom oh my god it's a ghost
everybody you know that's right Junior
yeah just gets applause yeah that's
right junior the names already candle I
used to sing in the studio back during
the Great Depression you know that's
right this used to be a radio studio
back in the 1930s did you sing songs on
the old NBC radio show yeah sure did
wrote all my own songs too of course my
little song surprise sound pretty
old-fashioned in corny today well I
don't think so at all I'll tell you
something we're going through some tough
times here and and and just like back in
the old days so maybe one of your
Depression era songs would cheer us up
right now what do you think it's okay
here's a little ditty I wrote right
after the big stock market crash of 29
okay lots of people didn't have much
money back then and I wrote this little
tune to cheer people up a little the
market crashed and that was quite a shot
now the poor folks are lined up
the blood they all need food and jobs
but I hate those lazy slobs and I'd love
to bash their heads in we're the rock
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute no that's a
horrible song too sentimental there's
all sentimental you can't go around
hitting people in the head with rocks
you're right it's easier just to whack
them with a hand up against man let's
change the subject well how about a
sweet little song used to sing for all
the ladies a song for the ladies that
sounds nice and sweet I just hope it's
not like the last song no don't worry
it's a charming little ditty here you go
Oh women should be branded like a cow my
god let's fire of those branding items
now we'll never have a save the mouth of
stuff with a man we hook them up like
oxen to a plow plow it again no no
sexist horrible yes thank you for the
booing that's the most sexist song I've
ever heard I'm surprised you weren't
murdered I was murdered yeah gang of
housewives knocked me out with the brick
and drowned me in it good I'm glad they
did we deserved a lot worse I'm just
glad you don't have those any songs
about Thanksgiving Oh actually I do have
a Thanksgiving song listen up oh wow
most folks eat their turkey and some pie
being a Russian whorehouse getting hot
once a heart this suit for cash be elbow
deep in hands
and all the opium and hookers I can buy
pretty do okay yeah yeah we're gonna
take a break we come back kanye west
[Applause]